coming up I'll be blue God versus party
wolf and here we go let's get blue got
up on stage
[Music]
GG's very own blue God won't take it
away brother talk about blue got a
little bit pretty much the only other
person who could be as decorated in
terms of tournament wins and maybe the
most consistent tournament player in
Soul Calibur six in the moment right
next to sin shin-chan right he has been
in top e I think maybe every one of the
top eight that he's entered he's also
gotten that thing he's talked for we
talked about how the man's within muscle
buster like that one walking on stage oh
man yeah I mean well he's he's just
giving us a speak let me guess
ah just wanted to give us a sneak
preview for the saviors tower
he's preset in ax mode Man 3 get set
oh my god that mean he's sandbagging
some sort is the best mode yeah coming
up next is egg cells very own party whoa
yeah this is your last chance qualifier
winner this is the man who basically
overcame the strongest players because
honestly any a lot of those LCQ players
could have been in this top eight in the
first place and he won against all of
them a lot of people who are just
straight-up favorite like like favorites
5 most of the community
fine party left right here and he looked
so so good Walter exactly look at him
wearing the fabulous black and pink
looking fresh but looking fresh right
now let's go ahead and listen to some
words from blue God about this so there
was a Gamestop sale where it was like by
two games get one free right and I went
with my cousin I picked the game he
picked the game and we couldn't decide
on the third game so like you know
whatever you just pick whatever game you
want to play and he bought Soul Calibur
five right that's a third game and I
just played it and I had a lot of fun
[Music]
and you heard my voice crack during the
picture of a blue guy but my god an
incredible player each and every time he
went from being blue boy to the blue god
this man is crazy at this game so
talented
his frame dad a matchup knowledge is so
ecstatic so excessive towards almost
every character the cast and was seeing
him apply that time and time again and
do punishes that he's a punishment God
okay the moment you punish comes up
frame perfect each time without a doubt
so excited to see that it also makes a
very old party we'll see yeah so I mean
you're actually talking about a lot of
quote-unquote frame-perfect punishes so
there's one thing that actually got
party wolf the wind during the LCQ is he
punished something so perfectly uh
versus saying that I was actually
sitting down in the the the chairs with
lake [ __ ] and he was like I didn't
actually know that he had a button that
could punish that they're linked or not
know right and so we were both flipping
and I mean if you want to talk about
frame perfect punishes party wolf
student of the game just a veritable
wealth of knowledge right sure he'd love
to teach it to other people he's always
a building conscious of community and
teaching everyone about the ways of
calibers
we just want to get a button check
underway it looks like first the song
party wolf when the game first started
he was definitely considered to be just
maybe the straight-up best at a point
and then you know running into character
crisis boat yeah she just won a
tournament so he won free packet Leno's
last year okay man oh we also came
second at NEC last year which is coming
up again so you know our boys weight has
a hot streak vibe going back on I like
it I like it
but one of the things I talked to rich
dicks about despite the fact that a lot
of people know him for what was
basically a character crisis his wrist
was talking about when he's at the curve
dislike screen he needs to look at what
he's comfortable with and what actually
is strong right and that that's what
he's been looking at me to kind of get
over that sort of here we go putting up
mad damage party well you get a garden
gate pressure there as well you got big
chillin okay run escape right there
there's the 6p right now switching to
sword stance trying to get it okay spear
little paw reaction I like it trying to
get the backdoor right there but
unfortunately that's just how it be for
4k is able to be blocked but that's only
about like negative 8 so it's gonna be
punished back door comes out
nice walk in the mid right there but
then there's the jumping and he's gonna
be able to sidestep right there blue god
pick in the first round KO colonel
they're going right away bring about
work
maybe the lethal hit Bing just like that
before take a yeah you're just gonna be
able to get the mix-up right and go
through the low on that that's all what
a sidestep right there from the blue boy
all right
Oh muscle buster will connect be careful
I warned you Oh another muscle Buster
right there and that's gonna do it blue
guard just kind of terrific think about
the whole scenario too was that like he
caught him saying okay okay you got me
I'm not to be able to chop those ankles
baby let's go okay I'm just packing up
both lethal hit check here we go
reversal edge will connect what becomes
are we getting today is up right now so
basically nothing happens on that he was
able to do the jump a right now matches
him low because yeah he recognizes the
the midgard Perry right okay so charge
comes out back away from me over reason
thank you oh we get out of that how dare
you yeah and the house is going down
rapidly though things to this bull
charge so he's got to make something
happen right here oh my goodness
oh and Avery belt blue bot being so
patient ok I have such a massive likely
there's no reason for me to press the
button here I'm gonna wait it out I'm
just gonna punish you but I tend to do
I'm in sort stance I can just I can hit
the fastest button I got no problem
exactly how it went down
first game party while thinking about it
a little bit taking a breather I mean
you know as well as he's quite strong
right so you really got to think about
the ways you got put into those
situations and you got to think about
like okay how can I avoid that for the
next time and that's probably what are
you thinking about one of the kids a
little bit of time but the muscle buster
is not gonna give you any time you know
God
get the lethal hit right there for Greg
okay set up I'm and catches the GI okay
one more set up jumps it okay to get out
of there hello and there it is yeah the
five eight the swords are just so old
good for your as well I got the axle
right now that's actually one of the
only like loads not muscle most attracts
they can be representative but you get
the side step on the floor for people
you know that can be bad but okay no
check on the throw there and these kids
are the launch of his own blue God says
haven't been a meter but part of will
finally gaining its own that's a lot of
damage before parquet gets walked okay
the low not close enough to be able to
be over and I guess it's because usually
he does so I was ready but actually
that's negative enough yeah and he gets
the lethal hit off that okay so now
party wolf has a lot of offensive no
messes going into this talk on the throw
though so he gods got a chance to be
able to fight back and he's gonna be
able to get to punish on that the mix-up
chance no okay good so let's right yeah
he doesn't have a lot of guard meter
right he's got to be able to put the
pressure on it here oh my gosh my be
nice really keep system by party what
they're gonna get a round up arm you
guys I think he only hit you only missed
that couple one else's
I think it was like literally only one
okay but that isn't all of us two blocks
and that is the punish right there
hey [ __ ] the mint for senior full charge
out of blue god he's trying to show him
the power of reason often acted oh
that's plus frames and a lot of damage
so real bad logs i punished you wanted
to lethal hit but no science I think hey
there's the Miss custom mix up on and
the electric Boogaloo a little chewy
oh wow just barely on the side of that
was able to whip on it right there drew
2-2 in rounds of Devadas on set point
don't but they do have even a meter
right now too so let's see what happens
a particles guard gauge int looking
mighty low my friends no I mean he's
working on the offense so strong that he
might actually start get it back nice
charges the muscle buster so he doesn't
have to deal with the 50/50 so charges
here
sole charge right back the power of
reason coming in I'm gonna look to try
and do something that we doing quite a
bit of car damage so party will run the
in forward come talk to me there we go
step right there and oh there's the
muscle buster that's rip with damage
wound up more possible mix-up here on
the blue got okay right here little DB
Oh what if he gets
oh there it is I mean you know when
you're up close against as well it is
50/50 City for sure so I it could be
really simple but and I mean blue vodkas
holding his own breath right there you
saw him to hold his hand to his chest
you can flex just her own feels like oh
dear
well your party won't came from a run
for his money on that one yeah like look
you've gotta breathe yes what an
incredible magic both of them so so
solid yeah but blue God definitely one
of the strongest players if not be
strongest player in America I mean I
would personally say so I know Lynn
Korres feels very similarly Billy horses
you know an easy contender for that
right job Jim but yeah so blue god